my brother and I are traveling through
China for a couple weeks and we noticed
that the Starbucks here is super fancy
super fancy so we are going to try all
their crazy drinks and we're gonna
report back to you we just like to ask
the barista just to kind of choose four
of the most unique drinks they have here
and that's what we're gonna try and then
we're also gonna have them choose their
favorite dessert here we're gonna try
that too and I'm really looking forward
to it because everything here looks way
different than at home I'm a little
worried about the color of the
marshmallows here I have never seen
drinks like this at a Starbucks in the
US they are perfectly decorated I'm so
overwhelmed I I'm just ready to dive in
what should we try first the beer float
your float latte I'm a little worried
because when we got it it was really big
and foamy and now it's kind of deflated
a little bit you see like it's a little
bubble pockets
it smells like an IPA it's like if
someone drink a beer out of this
yesterday like didn't wash it out and
then decide to make coffee in it it's
exactly what a latte with a little hint
of beer would taste like it's like a
pleasant frat house basement this is the
one I'm actually really excited for I'm
hoping it's like a some more hot
chocolate hybrid it's kind of got that
hot chocolate powder at the bottom seats
to it this is actually just a hot
chocolate mixed with the milk you had
after eating a bowl of Lucky Charms it's
all right I'm
well
[Music]
no I have the espresso mall wata here
it's like a whopper in coffee oh I don't
like that at all it's really sugary I
think it's actually pretty good I taste
like a whopper that's gotten bad and
then melted a little it's kind of a fun
way to get your caffeine fix but also a
kind of gross way to do it too this is
our last drink and it is definitely the
most colorful it looks a little bit like
an asparagus soup I love green tea so
I'm really excited for this one it's
very green tea I like it I think this is
actually the best one
this is the true star of the show I am a
coffee addict but I'm more of a
chocolate addicts and a coffee addict I
cannot wait
[Music]
I may assume that's the best thing that
matters who needs coffee
I love the Corolla dark chocolate pieces
on top add a little crunch there this is
the best thing we bought here if I find
this chocolate cake in the States
there's really gonna be a problem
because I'm gonna eat it way too often
[Music]
we're gonna finish the rest of these
before we leave definitely gonna finish
that cake too because start the show
right there and I guess we're gonna just
continue on our tour of China and we'll
be very fueled for the rest of the day
oh yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]